this is a very sophisticated discussion
of art history and yet it is told with
such lightness and such clarity I we had
lots of crazy ideas for how to present
this movie at one point pen suggest that
we presented as a video game so that
you'd see like Tim's life force on one
side and that bar would be going down as
he's painting along in the painting well
I got an email from Penn it was the
weirdest thing I've ever seen him write
it said I'm doing nothing but spending
time with my toddlers & Teller and I'm
going crazy he has a young family and he
said i need an adult conversation can
you please come to Vegas so I flew out
there and we sat down he said I don't
want to talk about show business please
or politics what do you got I said what
do you know about Vermeer he said the
painter I said yeah you know
photorealism saw one of his shows in New
York and I said well I think I figured
out how he how he painted he said what
do you mean and I realized that I had
the cam a video camera on my belt with a
clip on it and it said clip that's in
the movie where you're looking down
through the lens after in this
father-in-law experiment I had just done
that experiment and I showed him that he
said I totally get how this works it's
very similar to a magic trick it's
something we call mirror masking and he
saw what he going to do with this I said
well I want to paint something that
looks more like a Vermeer and maybe
write a paper about it or make a youtube
video or something and he said well
that's a really stupid idea you know I
said why he said you know this could be
a movie we should try to make a movie
out of this it was Tim and pen and then
Penn called teller who's the de facto
director of the Penn & Teller show and
then Penn called me and so I had an
interesting kind of vantage point
because Penn and Teller have known Tim
for decades I've guess about 25 years
maybe and love him and I came aboard I
have known
Penn & Teller for a long time I worked
with a pen doing the aristocrats but I
didn't know yes another film that's
really how did a movie about one joke is
kind of like a man trying to paint a
painting these are on makeable
documentaries about midway through the
project which is as we said we kept
thinking was going to take a year Oh
it'll just take one more year okay and
another year and about a midway through
I fell down the rabbit hole that Tim
refers to as ver myrial disease and I I
found myself totally compelled not be by
friendship or anything like that just be
just totally compelled and for myself I
thought oh my gosh if I who had no
native entry you know interest in the
subject matter I'm so compelled maybe
it's compelling maybe something that I'm
I'm fairly good at is finding the simple
thing at the core of something you need
to know a lot in order to follow every
step as you're going through there and I
used to be a schoolteacher I was a
schoolteacher for six years I taught
Latin in a secondary school which may be
may be good preparation for this movie
you know because Latin doesn't have a
reputation for being the most
interesting thing in the world and
watching a guy painting a painting
doesn't sound on paper like it could be
you know an entertaining and delightful
thing especially when it's really this
complicated so I think he was thinking
that probably I would find that I would
find the plot line in it and you know
when when you when you have an
experience like when you're done with
today you don't know what the content of
your day was until you go back and tell
yourself the story of the day and when
you do that you pick out these little
pieces of bits and pieces and you end up
telling yourself the story well this
this is a this is a one in one sense of
this is an adventure detective story
right as a three hundred fifty year old
mystery that Tim solves in in another
one of these in another incarnation of
this this is penn telling you a story
about his buddy who goes on this crazy
adventure and we were we spend a lot of
time really trying to find
what was what was this simple central
action that we could hang all of this on
because it's not a polemic I mean this
is not Tim going oh here's how you solve
the Vermeer problem it's really about
getting on board with a guy who has an
idea and this is so willing to do the
work of really really testing that idea
and and that it's all on a work of art
it was just it was hard to come up with
what turns out to be the key sentence in
this which is my friend Tim painted a
Vermeer he painted a Vermeer in a
warehouse in Texas you know that's
that's the that's the sort of key that
unlocked the movie for us I interviewed
Tim about halfway through the process in
his warehouse in Texas which is why it's
lit beautifully just like Vermeer and
and I said Tim where you're going to
succeed and then those opening words of
the film at night when I'm laying in bed
now I know that laying is wrong because
I'm an old Latin teacher sorry about
that time yeah but but we and we thought
about looping it but then we thought no
this is tim this is this is tim and we
want to be honest about this but a night
and night what I'm laying in bed
thinking about all trying to get to
sleep all I can think about is this goal
of painting her premiere when that when
that sentence came out as a possibility
of opening the movie then the story
suddenly came more and more into focus
but the conversation did continue yeah
it did just after that on the cutting
room floor it Keller says well you know
if if you don't succeed this is going to
be a very different film and I said
there ain't going to be no film if it
doesn't work he said oh yes there well
this this film could really couldn't
have been made this way even five years
ago and it couldn't have been made
really I think with anybody else but but
Tim or somebody as as savvy as he is to
technology because a lot of this a lot
of the photography of Tim doing the
painting is is really a man's
autobiographical journal done with
cameras that he himself has set up every
morning and when Tim is talking to you
from the from the screen he's not really
talking to me he's talking to Farley
we'd set up a red camera right with it
was sort of set up like a teleprompter
so the Tim could looks straight into a
skype feed of Farley debriefing him at
the end of day every day one of the
things tell her noticed early
unfortunately was that I couldn't really
look into a camera lens and you know be
it all natural I mean it's just so
foreign to me to be on that side of the
lens and you know this this red camera
with the matte box and the you know
wireless microphone tenes and you know
all this stuff and taller said you're
looking at a giant ant that's about to
attack you and it's intimidating and and
so teller wanted me to to do this video
diary every day and so knowing that I
you know you know would be intimidated
by this camera it was we set up a video
skype with farley so I was just talking
to Farley and I saw Farley's face but
I'm looking straight into the camera
lens and that probably has a subtle
psychological effect in the film but I'm
talking when I clearly talk to you I'm
talking to her I was a common
denominator I explained this super
complicated stuff to somebody who
doesn't have a clue and so that I could
understand which was helpful and you
plan to exhibit the painting we don't
have any plans yet it's still above my
fireplace and we did we did take it to
Telluride when we when we premiered the
film we took it to Telluride and we had
this theater that had maybe 600 people
in it that were quite delighted by the
movie and Tim walked down the aisle and
they all rose to their feet and then Tim
said I have something to show you and
pulled a hold
drape off the of the picture and it was
really wild it was a people swarmed to
the stage and surrounded it like a holy
icon and you know when people think when
people say it it does this movie make
vermeer less of a great artist and you
look at their reaction to this painting
that this non painter has done just as a
scientific experiment you go know the
more you know about how how much goes
into a work of art the more you love it